so recently someone had a question what
have I been eating lately and what is my
intermittent fasting routine so I want
to talk about that in this video I have
some other videos and you're gonna find
it's very similar to the last video so I
I'm not changing very often I just I can
pretty much eat the same thing every
single day
Karen cannot just she has to vary it up
so this is what I do in the morning five
o'clock I get up I go to bed at 10:30
doing this in a minute fasting I need
less sleep okay so I do my coffee
organic and sometimes I use half and
half but I prefer to use heavy cream
okay and it's grass-fed and then I do
one packet of xylitol now the amount of
coffee I drink is a very small cup okay
because I abused myself in college I
used to drink pots of coffee and I burn
up madrina 'ls so I no longer do that I
just have one small cup and I'm good for
the whole day so I'll do that at 5 at 6
I will get some water with lemon usually
I'll do 1 to 2 ounces of organic lemon
juice sometimes they'll use real lemons
and I'll have like maybe I number 12 the
16 ounces of water and that's when I
take my vitamins okay so that's at 6 and
then I'm not gonna eat until between 1
and 3 o'clock now I am absolutely not
hungry
at this point of the day if I had my way
I would actually just do one meal a day
all that right but I don't because I
lose too much weight I'm six-two I weigh
180 pounds if I do one meal a day I will
get down to like 177 and I don't like
that so I like 180 I feel comfortable
with that
and but it's very difficult to consume
that many calories because I would have
to consume them like I don't know 3,000
to 3,500 calories in one meal and that's
really really tough so I'll break it up
between two meals so the first meal is
between 1 and 3 maybe 2 o'clock on
average okay so and the first meal I'll
do my 4 eggs they're pasture raised
organic eggs ok when you see free-range
it doesn't mean anything or it says with
vegetarian feed that
they're doing you know like GMO grains
you want organic and you want
pasture-raised okay and I normally try
to get these at the farmers market okay
four ounces of bacon and it's not the
type of bacon you might think I get it
from the farmers market or I will get it
at a healthy store and it's going to be
organic so how much is four ounces if
you take one of those packs and you cut
it in half that's how much I consume
some people think I have a pound of
bacon a day I don't so it's four ounces
it's not that much and believe it or not
bacon is not as fat as you think because
all the fat gets fried off so it's
there's a lot of other meats that are a
lot fatter than bacon I just like bacon
my body likes it it has a lot of b1 you
don't have to do bacon that's just what
I do okay three ounces of cheese I
really like the sheep cheese or goat
cheese I'll cut it up in small pieces
and I will fry the eggs and I'll put the
cheese on top and then what I'll do is
I'll flip it over easy and then I'll put
the bacon on top of that note the cheese
I usually do European cheese
high-quality organic grass-fed cheese
1/4 cup olives that's in my egg mixture
and maybe one tomato so that's pretty
much for my first meal so you can see
it's mostly protein and fat now between
5 & 6
I'll have the second meal now at this
point I am absolutely not hungry because
I just ate a few hours ago but I'm
trying to keep my meals within a four
maybe three to four hour window so I can
have 20 or 21 hours of fasting that's
what I want to do okay
so between 5 & 6 I'll have my second
meal I'll start with a huge salad
between 7 to 10 cups
I don't do spinach okay I will do
lettuce leap type salad from the health
food store or the Farmers Market and
I'll usually cut a bell pepper I'll do
some tomato
maybe cabbage maybe kale and I'll cut it
up put it in my salad and I also put
some Parmesan cheese on the salad I use
olive oil and balsamic vinaigrette okay
because it's almost impossible to find a
good dress
at the grocery store so I'll do the
salad take my time to eat that and I
will then have my protein okay on
average 7 ounces I'll do sardines okay
there with the bones and with the skin
you get more nutrients from that
especially calcium and more omega-3
fatty acids I made you the burger and of
course it's high-quality its grass-fed
organic okay
I like doing salmon a lot so it's
wild-caught I'll do shrimp I'll do hot
dogs not the regular hot dogs that you
might think I will get them at the
farmers market and they're grass-fed and
they're very healthy and then sometimes
I'll do a steak okay so that's pretty
much what I will consume for my protein
if I'm doing a burger or hot dogs I will
add mustard to that not ketchup and
sometimes I'll add some fermented
vegetables like sauerkraut something
like that then I'll have some nuts
pecans or pistachios so I'm very
consistent I can do this my body runs on
it and I'm not going to eat anything
from that point on until the next day
all right guys so there you have it very
boring that's what I eat in a nut shell
no pun intended
so if you want to get notified with all
my content click the notification bell
next to subscribed